crime across america but especially in
blue cities and blue states is going
through the roof right now and you know
it's going through the roof when even on
cnn they can't deny it here's cnn's john
avalon
talking about the crime situation in
democrat-run cities robbery has jumped
19
but the story in different cities
specifically in different neighborhoods
is all over the map in los angeles
murders hit a 15-year high in the first
six months of the year in philadelphia
the city of brotherly love shootings
have spiked to record highs climbing
hundreds of lives while 100 miles to the
north new york city has seen murders and
shootings actually decline year over
year but robberies and assaults are up
big time
now remember these are not just
statistics they are people's lives when
the state legislature finally acted on
criminal justice this summer they
decided to focus on semantics instead of
solutions officially replacing the term
inmate with incarcerated person in state
laws seriously that's what they did
now sometimes we forget that public
safety is a fundamental civil right and
it's often lower income neighborhoods
that suffer the most from high crime
while wealthier neighborhoods stay
relatively safe
in fact black and hispanic democrats are
more likely than white democrats to
support increased spending on local
police that's according to a pew survey
from late last year
look politicizing crime seeks to gain
from other people's pain but trying to
ignore crime for ideological reasons is
both callous and clueless and it's sure
to promote a political backlash okay so
that is cnn admitting that something is
going wrong in democrat cities now who's
in charge of democrat-run cities
democrats it's incredible and you may
remember that we had about two years as
the democrats were burning down cities
and you had to board up your store and
say how much you love black lives matter
so that they wouldn't burn your story
down
the democrats were also
demonizing and defunding the police
something they say now that they didn't
do but we have video of them doing it
so we've been talking about defunding
the police there's some issues that we
asked police to do like mental health
issues or policing in schools and all
the rest that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around suck
it up defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
i applaud eric garcetti for doing what
he's done not only do we need to
disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department so yes defund your butts
defund you yes i support the
reallocation of resources
from nypd we will be moving funding from
the nypd to youth initiatives and social
services yes i support the defund
movement i think you do all those other
things you don't need all the money
that's going in the police department so
yeah i mean the spirit of it i i do
support that defunding police means
defunding police if these reports are
accurate then these proposed cuts to the
nypd budget are a disingenuous illusion
this is not a victory the freshman
democrat adding the fight to defund
policing will continue
okay so as you guys saw at the top of
that clip there are about six more
minutes of that
but we only showed you about a minute of
it but those were officials in places
like minneapolis and places like san
francisco and l.a
and places like what else was on there
detroit new york city and they are all
democrat run these were their own people
who they voted in to say we would like
less law and order then crime exploded
we'll get into that in just a second
crime explodes all over and then many of
those very same people backtrack their
words because there's a cause right the
cause is defunding the police and the
effect is oh a lot of murder
so this is a problem